years ago you weren't allowed to try
things on before you bought them then
one Savvy business owner created a
fitting room their sales presumably
skyrocketed so much so that it's now a
standard practice in all clothing stores
here's why adjusting room is so powerful
it's all three types of lead magnets in
one you get to try something like a
trial it also reveals a problem once you
try something on you might find out that
you need something different than you
intended and once you find a shirt that
you like a good salesperson would say do
you want pants that go with it it
becomes step one in a multi-step sales
process of creating an outfit so if you
can try and get a lead man that does all
three reveals a problem giv them a taste
of the solution and shows it as a
smaller piece of a much bigger pie once
they increase their perspective